[Musique]
à cannes à une vie plus compliqué que ce
que vous croyez
tu t'es jamais dit connais tous
prédestiné d'enfants et notre job c'est
de jouer notre rôle quand vient le tour
ce mec c'est qui
c'est lui le protecteur la destinée
l'avenir d'istanbul dépendent de lui on
attend ce moment depuis des années on et
déloyaux noyau à quoi à toi si jamais
l'immortel apprend que le protecteur est
de retour il passera immédiatement
l'action et tuera tous les habitants de
cette ville
il est trop faible ce mec il n'est pas
prêt
tu va l'entraîner
le moment d'agir est arrivé
[Musique]
si vous voulez être avec lui vous devez
vous attendre à des surprises le monde
secret
et vous quel est vôtre
qu'est ce que tu veux que je te dise
exactement mairie de même en costard tu
me plaît pas
[Musique]
tu est le descendant du protecteur